self-esteem if I felt like the need to
urinate it would stop me from urinating
in front of
[Music]
you first of all I'd like to say
something about how the book came to be
get came to have its title Mirror Mirror
it's called um its original title the
title I wrote it under um was because
you're worth it
um and it was stimulated by that uh
famous advertising slogan of L'Oreal the
very useful French firm which makes
things that everybody needs um and um
the way the the advertising campaign
stimulated the book was it got me
thinking why do I hate that campaign
slogan so much um every time I saw it
and it was very common certainly eight
or nine years ago um I felt this sort of
rising tide of visceral anger and
frustration and hatred for the modern
world and and um of course I was getting
old at the time but still um and and I I
that puzzled me I was puzzled by my own
reactions why did I take against it with
this kind of as I say sort of visceral
horror
um and so I started to think about that
and as I thought about it I started to
deal with the emotions of self love and
um I found the landscape was much more
complicated than I'd ever imagined it to
be so if we think of some of the words
which get thrown about um we might think
of
narcissism conceit uh vanity Pride
self-esteem
um all of those are used I think largely
interchangeably by many people but in
fact I think there differences uh one
difference I was alerted to uh by my
friend Anthony gring we were talking
about his new College of the humanities
now deceased
unfortunately um and uh he recounted he
encountered he he knew Freddy a Freddy a
was one of his teachers um Freddy a was
a famous philosopher for those of you
who are very young who um appeared on
the brains trust and things and um
Freddy sent to said to Anthony one day
you know Anthony people say that I'm
vain and it's quite true but I'm not
conceited and that's you know that's
sort of paradoxical isn't it what's the
what's the contrast he got in mind well
I think one contrast I'm not sure it's
the one he had in mind but a contrast I
would make is something like this that
if you're
conceited you're on the way to
narcissism you're on the way to taking
no notice of other people um that is you
sail through life
self-sufficiently you don't see the need
to take advice from other people you
don't see NE even see the need to debate
your ideas with other people you're as
it were happy in your own skin or in
your own brain and um that's a
Affliction I think because many people
who are conceited are for that very
reason they're not conversible they're
not used to having their ideas
challenged they don't hear
challenges um Freddy wasn't like that
but Freddy was vain now what does vain
mean well I think it comes in various
flavors um but one thing that I think is
characteristic of vanity is a greed it's
a greed need for Applause you want the
admiration of other people and you want
it too much um I think we all like the
admiration of other people um you like
it when people say oh well done that was
jolly good show so on and so on um you
you um you feel a little glow of Pride
um and a vain
person doesn't really care whether he
deserved the app Applause as long as he
gets the Applause or she I use pronouns
interchangeably I'm very modern like
that
um um as long as you get the Applause
you youever you feel you've you've won
something um and of course like any
desire it can get out of hand it can
turn into a lust uh a lust for self for
esteem from other people
um seems to be character characteristic
of one form of vanity funly enough I
think at the other end of the scale
there's a slightly different form of
vanity which approaches conceit I've
already said about conceit that it's a
kind of indifference to the views of
other people and there is a kind of
vanity which um is probably illustrated
by as it were the the characteristic
look of a model on a catwalk if you
think of the characteristic looks of
models on
catwalks they don't smile at you they
don't take any notice of you they sort
of stride along looking very very
pleased with themselves um and that's
say an exercise of
vanity uh and the interesting thing is
that it's quite
attractive these to it's sells clothes
um so what why do we find that
attractive cuz in real life
is not at all attractive if somebody's
got their nose stuck in the air and they
take no notice of you um it's demeaning
to you which is unpleasant it's a kind
of little dig or insult to your own
self-esteem which is very unpleasant so
why is it usable to sell clothes and in
fact why did L'Oreal's advertisement
work so well it sold perfumes and other
tat um
so so so why does just been told you're
worth it have um have this sort of
magnetic effect on people so I began to
think that there's Mysteries here um
narcissism I think is this the the far
end of
conceit um in the Greek myth
narcissus um was solitary he lived alone
in the countryside where he tended to
sheep he was a Shepherd boy um and his
only sort of human contact or semi human
contact was the nymph
Echo and um narcissist heard the words
of
echo but of course Ekko does nothing but
repeat the words he says so in this case
Echo was repeating to narcissist his own
words um and that's quite you know it's
it's an insight into a certain aspect of
our Natures um it's easy and sometimes
quite Pleasant to rehearse in our Mind's
Eye the words we imagine other people to
be using about us um I mean people
obviously sa me the time you know
frightfully good
lecturer terribly
intelligent you know distinguished
career sells lots of
books um at least if I tell myself that
that's true it's rather Pleasant for a
while um and words I don't use about
myself include well you can all guess
um fat aged ugly past his
prime pity pity we didn't hear him 30
years
earlier so um so in the myth of course
narcissus only hears Eko and you imagine
he only hears Eko saying nice things
about him um and of course he's falls in
love more directly visually because he
sees his own image reflected in a pool
of water and this obsesses him so much
that he Fades away dies
and um and leaves behind no
body um narcissus was always as it were
incorporeal he wasn't really a person
really a person amongst others because
to be a person is to find yourself as a
person amongst other persons so so there
was something telling Greek myths often
have this amazing kick in them they the
the um the detail that somehow counts
and I think this detail of narcissus he
turned into the flow the narciss the
daffodil or the um um narcissus tribe
flowers so so that was the alternative
for him um and I think the myth tells us
that that kind of obsessive self esteem
or obsessive love of yourself obsessive
self-concern um is eventually killing
it's not kills you but it leaves you as
it were without effect on the rest of
people on the other people around
you so in a sense it's self- nullifying
because you're in love with yourself but
your love of
yourself prevents you being a person
amongst other people and it prevents you
having any kind of real
Legacy so here we've got narcissism
narcissism um conceit and vanity uh let
me return to vanity the two different
polls the pole when it's quite near to
conceit and the pole when it's far away
from conceit when it's a a Greed for the
admiration of other
people
um as I say that when it goes to being
Greed for the admiration of other people
it's something that we can all recognize
we all like it as I said earlier um when
people can be heard to be saying good
things things about us that's nice or to
applauding our performances that's nice
too um but it can be overdone obviously
if it's under
control it probably amounts to
self-esteem and this is the
penultimate aspect of people I'd like to
talk about
self-esteem um has been described it's
described by
Milton as second only to Faith as a good
thing as a
virtue um it's that's slightly
surprising because in the Christian
tradition anyhow because pride is the
worst of the seven deadly sins it's the
fountain from which all the others
spring so the Christian tradition is
very down on pride and you might think
that pride and self-esteem are close
cousins but here's Milton who's a very
good Christian telling us that
self-esteem
is Noble it's a good thing and you can
see again what he means
um uh it's your
self-esteem which is appealed to when
the um School Master says um you've um
let me down you've let the school down
but worst of all you've let yourself
down and the poor Chas and school pupil
goes away feeling lousy about himself
and vows to
reform they don't reform but they vow to
reform and um so you've let yourself
down self-esteem is
the uh the attitude towards the self
which prevents you letting yourself down
um it would stop me for example from if
I felt like the need to urinate it would
stop me from urinating in front of you
and feel I feel I'd let myself down if I
did
that as well as losing my audience um um
so uh so so self-esteem is um I think
what Milton's getting at is that
self-esteem is the um the aspect of your
image of yourself which prevents you
from letting yourself down from becoming
a a laughing stock or doing something so
conspicuously silly or bad or um
unworthy um that you're going to lose
face you're going to lose credibility in
the eyes of other people and put like
that self-esteem is necessary it keeps
us on the straight and narrow or nearly
on the straight and narrow like makes us
like to appear to be on the straight and
narrow um and that's at least halfway to
being a good person to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest
ideas